the queen comes from an era where things
were built to last
[Music]
a jubilee is a celebration not just of a
long lasting monarch but of where we've
come from and who we are today
seven decades ago the first type of
morris minor was rolling off production
lines post-war britain looked to the
future
and did so with a new youthful monarch
who'd served as a mechanic and truck
driver in the war
earning a respect within the military
that has only grown
our captain general
the person who we work for effectively
um in every way for
the longest time she's been
in charge of the army it's who we all
take our commission for who signs our
real warrants when we when we take the
oath so she means a great deal
in abingdon near to where the morris
minor was made there's an exhibition to
celebrate this second elizabethan era
the queen's long reign is a living
thread to any moment in british history
since the war the queen opened this very
building in 1956
and she's been on a journey with us up
until present day opening scientific
establishments in the area
pandemonium paid a visit to the usa four
shaggy minstrels the beatles under her
reign britain has led the way to a more
creative liberal and open global society
but there's been a painful transition
from an industrial-led nation
to a more financial service-based
economy that has benefited some more
than others
globally the country's transitioned from
ruling nations to maintaining the
closest possible ties and in that the
queen's role as the head of the
commonwealth is seen by many as crucial
there was testament to it in the crowds
flocking to celebrate her life she came
to uganda we are from malawi some of us
malawi here we are just different
countries when we look at those those
trips that she did around the
commonwealth were they important do they
matter why do they matter they brought
you know love to the community they
brought the togetherness and knowing
that she's selfless traveling and making
impact to the globe through the waste
charitable deeds that's when we see
even new roads being built yes
everything is revamped everything is
renewed because the queen is coming
in uganda we had a queensway
and that was the highway and it was a
beautiful way but when she goes royalty
means a new road
[Applause]
the queen can attract numbers that even
rock stars couldn't pull and in an
ever-changing world she remained
something familiar predictable
unchanging
so she still commands ceremonial majesty
and the crowd still stop and cheer when
her car unexpectedly arrives in the
palace entrance
70 years ago we lived in a country which
was bound by deference it was a class
within society as a society which was
very constrained and restrained the
monarchy now reflects as it did 70 years
ago
the society of 2022 and that takes a lot
of care and it takes leadership and i
think it was the leadership of the queen
in particular to understand that changes
were required but in a very gradual way
in recent times the queen has remained a
symbol of unity addressing the nation
during covid she sent a reassuring
message we will be with our friends
again we'll be with our families again
we will meet again
even setting an example at her husband's
funeral sat alone while the world
watched
but behind all the ceremony and
formality she has remained an enigma a
largely unknown woman
in a world that is now flooded with
opinion we still don't know what she's
thinking
jason farrell sky news